welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season two
followed up its recent trailer with more
footage in a disney plus promo
that you might have missed because wanda
and vision kind of dominated headlines
with their silly halloween costumes but
uh you really should check this out
you may think you have some idea what
you're in possession of
but you do not
hamilton black beauty dad get that
non-star wars stuff out of this cantina
what else have we got here
wherever i go he goes
so in this footage we finally hear the
voice of dark saber wield and mop gideon
although this exact audio was a line
from the final minutes of episode 7 last
season
you may think you have some idea of what
you are in possession of
but you do not there's also this shot of
mando on the speeder bike on tatooine
which
upon closer examination appears to be
toting some familiar cargo on the far
back of that bike looks like armor with
a blue and orange apparatus
very similar to the z6 jetpack famously
worn by boba fett
and to the slight right you can also see
what looks like
boba fett's mandalorian helmet facing
toward the bike these new details do
clarify a lot of the findings i was able
to dig up in my in-depth analysis of the
trailer so here i'm now going to break
down what this all means how it's all
connected
spoiler warning in case you want to go
into manual season 2 blind
so i was previously brainstorming that
maybe the planet with the town that
mando and baby yoda are visiting in the
trailer could be lothal
which i pronounced perfectly in the last
video the home of ezra bridger in star
wars rebels a planet known to be rich in
the dunium ore used in star destroyer
construction
and a jedi temple with possible links to
the yoda species origin
but along with those creepy jawa eyes
from the shadows pay close attention to
the moment mando strings up that other
figure yeah that uh
that's the distinctive bellow of a
tuscan raider and while jawas are known
to be nomadic traders who show up on
multiple planets it's just a bit
more rare to see tuscan raiders anywhere
other than a desert planet like tatooine
also that clearly anti-imperial graffiti
on the walls corresponds to the
violent stormtrooper pike display seen
on tatooine last season
these folks hate imps and they aren't
afraid to let you know you know it'd be
great if we could just
ask this dude what planet we're on but i
don't speak tuscan
luckily language barriers are a thing of
the past thanks to our sponsor babel the
number one
language learning app in the world right
now i am not able to travel
internationally but it is something i
really love so i've been prepping for my
next trip by brushing up on some
german using babel so that when i'm
finally able to visit a new country
again i'll be able to get around and
connect with the locals
that's what babel specializes in as it's
aimed at preparing you for real-life
encounters and situations
it also has no ads those are real life
encounters i'm already getting plenty of
like here's my babel german course goes
hello eric
you'll learn how to greet people
informally and ask people how they're
doing which is you know
step one anytime you're traveling
internationally it also gives you a
nifty sound check so you know how to say
the german eye because vowels are
different in other languages i've played
around with learning through an app
before but the free app seemed too
basic and really not that effective
babel is way better than other apps and
learning methods actually university
studies have shown
that 15 hours of using babel is the
equivalent of a semester of college
spanish
think about it 15 hours that's like 30
minutes a day for like 30 days
yeah yeah head to my link below right
now to get 50
off for six months for a limited time
only click that link in the description
to start learning with babble today
so yes this planet on the mandalorian
season two trailer most likely tatooine
and i believe this leads directly to
mando entering that fighting arena where
he meets with gor koresh the abyssian
cyclops species we have actually seen
another member of on tatooine
and the sparring gomorians other species
we have seen on tatooine
and i believe this whole room all these
colorful characters could be
the remnants of the gang of jabba the
hutt filling the void of spice running
and organized crime on tatooine
in the five years since jabba died in
the opening act of return of the jedi
all these criminals now reorganized
under different leadership
actually if you look on the far side of
that fighting ring there is a pale
figure with
long appendages not unlike the laku of a
male twilik perhaps even those of
bib fortuna top advisor to jabba the
hutt it was for a time believed that
fortuna died when the sail barge
exploded but as is the case for pretty
much every star wars character there
exists a legend's backstory
detailing fortuna's secret plot to
betray
and to assassinate jabba the hutt luke's
arrival diverted this plan and after
leia strangled jabba fortuna actually
escaped that exploding yacht and
returned to jabba's palace where the
bomar monks he gets fired with arrived
to steal his brain for their
spider-droid walkers
it's a fun one now maybe this is fortuna
here maybe it isn't
but yeah the leftover elements of java
syndicate would be the criminal entity
mando would check
in with on tatooine if you read chuck
wendig's aftermath described how after
the galactic civil war the hutts were in
disarray
overtaken by nicto crime cartels this
could be the organization
gore koresh now represents notice their
exchange it's interesting
you know this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes
so i've heard which poses the question
where did gorkosh hear that mando's
reputation must precede him
implying that his last trip to tatooine
and episode five of last season
left an impression with people like
pelimoto
fenik shand whom we believe to now be in
the hands of boba that based on some
clues in that final shot of that episode
check out my breakdown for those clues
but yeah that moment was absolutely a
loose thread that season two will almost
certainly explore
if for no other reason then boba fett's
mandalorian armor is
best guard that denjarin would be eager
to get his hands on to return to the
armorer since this mandalorian sex
believes that all best guard in the
universe was stolen from the mandalorian
people
this could be part of what we're seeing
here on the speeder bike if indeed that
is boba fett's jet pack and helmet now
an important question
if you were to take boba fett's armor
from him is he still
boba fett like is he still the boba fett
that we know and love and are willing to
pay seven dollars a month to disney plus
to watch
on one hand yeah totally tamar morrison
could still act the [ __ ] out of this
bounty hunter armor or no armor
and yeah the prequels established boba's
background as that stinkface little
clone ward of jango fett on kamino but
on the other hand
the whole appeal of boba fett is really
that mandalorian helmet let's be honest
the helmet the gear the weaponry slave
one he's a man of few words he's a
struttin mystery we hardly got to know
and
really probably never want to know that
much about that's why he's fun
it's really honestly the same appeal
that dave filoni and john favreau are
using for the mandalorian dinjarin who
despite pedro pascal's indelible charm
remains in my opinion a far more
intriguing character when the helmet is
left on
we actually have an episode a big
question coming up in the pipeline
explaining how and why the mandalorian
series is kind of changing the rules of
why
these mandalorian characters hide their
faces under their helmets compared to
the mandalorians of the animated series
which
i guess aren't afraid of a little
vitamin d so instead i think mando's
attempt to track down fenix shan will
lead to a struggle in which mando tries
to take back boba fett's best scar armor
but boba fett offers him something in
exchange for that armor back so that he
could get restored in that iconic look
that we all had action figures of but in
a plot that still explains why they
would need morrison to be cast in this
role and the price boba fett pays to get
his armor back
information the location of boba fett's
origin planet kamino
the old cloning facility that was so
secret it didn't even show up on the
jedi archive star maps
perhaps the archives are incomplete if
an item does not appear in our records
it does not exist jocasta knew okay
boomer last season dr pershing
wore camino insignia when he was running
those tests on baby oda
leading many of us to believe that baby
oda could have been genetically
engineered on kamino
especially since cloning technology was
an ongoing thing in the star wars
universe established by the rise of
skywalker
somehow palpatine returned dark science
cloning secret sony that's it i'm sorry
if that triggered you
now yes kawil did suggest that baby yoda
didn't look genetically engineered i
don't think it was
engineered i've worked in the gene farms
this one looks evolved but blurg herders
are probably wrong about a lot of things
and that camino patch meant something
maybe this mandalorian season will head
to camino but ultimately i suspect i
hope
that baby oda's origin while maybe
connected to genetic engineering
is a bit more complex than yoda clone
just surprises felony
you can discuss these theories with me
on new rockstar's official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on
instagram ea boss follow new rockstars
thanks for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
foreign
[Music]